Open AI recently made it crystal clear
they reserve the right to change what
you get, throttle your access, and raise
your prices whenever they feel like it.
And they're not alone. That's the moment
I realized I don't actually own anything
that I'm paying for in AI. So, I spent a
week replacing the $120 a month I was
spending on AI subscriptions with things
actually in my control. You could do
this, too, for less than the cost of 1
month you're already paying to have some
tech company read all your prompts and
sell the data. And the secret is this
little baby right here. This is a
Raspberry Pi. Now, don't be intimidated.
I know it looks a little scary, but this
is basically just a mini computer that's
super low power and perfect for running
your own home server. You could either
buy a Raspberry Pi, or if you're cheap
like me, don't want to fork any moolah
over, any old laptop you have sitting at
the bottom of your closet will work,
too. Don't worry about the specs unless
you have one running off a hamster
wheel. You'll be good. And the cost
after that is basically only pennies of
electricity to power it. Now, let me ask
if you've ever been in the same position
as me. You're in the middle of something
important. You've got a workflow, a
rhythm, you're getting stuff done, and
poof, ChatGPT hits you with a rate
limit. Or the model you were using gets
downgraded on your tier without notice.
Or you're paying $20 a month for Claude,
another $20 for ChatGPT, another $20 for
Perplexity, and suddenly you're doing
the math and you realize you're
hemorrhaging $120 a month to AI
companies who truly do not care about
you. Are you really going to keep
forking over another 20 bucks a month
every time a new model drops and they
decide your old tier doesn't cut it
anymore? Hell no, we're done with that.
You can buy one of these pies like I
have right here, or with just a little
configuration to your old laptop, you
can run your own personal ChatGPT
completely for free and completely open
source with two programs, Ollama and
Open Web UI. And open source just means
that the code of the program is
completely public and maintained by the
public rather than one tech company.
Ollama is basically the engine. It lets
you download and run powerful AI models.
We're talking Llama 4, Deep Seek,
Mistral, Qwen, all directly on your own
machine. No cloud, no subscription, no
one reading your prompts. And Open Web
UI is the beautiful interface that sits
on top of it. It gives you that familiar
ChatGPT style chat window, dark mode,
conversation history, multimodal
switching, but it's 100% running on your
own hardware. This isn't some dinky
little terminal where you're typing
commands into a black box. This is a
full end-to-end AI chat experience that
honestly rivals ChatGPT and Claude
completely for free. But Tucker, what if
my computer isn't powerful enough? What
if I can't run the big models? Buddy,
it's 2026.
There are so many ways around this. I
got you. Don't worry. For lighter
hardware, your old laptop, your
Raspberry Pi models like Llama 3.18B or
Mistral 7B run beautifully and are
incredibly capable for most day-to-day
tasks. Writing, summarizing,
brainstorming, answering questions done.
You won't notice the difference for 90%
of what you use AI for. And if you want
to be extra resourceful, something I've
heard about that I would never, never,
ever do myself, there are certain API
providers out there where you can get
access to frontier models for
essentially free or nearly nothing
through free tier API keys. All
completely above board, of course. So
now you've got your AI chat sorted. But
that is just the tip of the iceberg.
These tech companies, their whole
business model is to get you hooked for
life on subscriptions. They want you to
never cancel. Are you tired of paying
$20 a month for Perplexity just to have
an AI that can search the web for you?
There's a self-hosted, open-source
alternative called Perplexica. It
replicates the exact same experience,
AI-powered web search with cited
sources, but it runs on your own machine
using your own local models through
Ollama. Your search queries never go to
anyone's servers. Perplexity even uses
SearXNG under the hood, which is itself
a privacy-first, open-source search
engine. Two birds, one stone, $0 a
month. Are you tired of paying for
Midjourney $10, $30, $60 a month just to
generate images and have every single
one of them owned by their servers,
their terms, their rules? There's an
open-source image generation stack
called Stable Diffusion with a
powerhouse interface called ComfyUI.
This is a local Midjourney. You run it
on your own machine. It pulls from
models like Efflux, which in 2026
genuinely rivals Midjourney quality, and
every image you generate is private,
unlimited, and completely free. You own
it. No one can take it down. No one can
ban your account and make your entire
library disappear. And it goes even
deeper. One of my personal favorite
things I love to use is this. And don't
get me started on how much I hate paying
for these AI writing assistants. You
know the ones. Grammarly at $30 a month,
Jasper at $49 a month. For what? To have
an AI polish your sentences on some
company's server where they log
everything you write? There are
open-source, self-hosted writing
assistants you can plug directly into
your browser and text editor using your
own local Llama models. You can set up a
browser extension that talks to your
local AI and gives you grammar, tone,
and rewriting suggestions for free
without a single word you type ever
leaving your device. These are just the
start. I'm giving you these examples to
show you that there's a free and
open-source version of everything you
already pay for in AI. I know it's a
little intimidating, and I am by no
means an expert in home servers or
setting any of this up, but I am one
thing: cheap as hell and determined.
When I did the math and I figured out
how much I was spending $20 here, $20
there, $30 somewhere else, I knew there
had to be better alternatives out there.
And now even my AI coding assistant runs
fully locally, so none of my code or
proprietary logic is going out to the
cloud at all. And I can access it from
anywhere on my home network. The good
news is there's so much information out
there to help you set this up,
especially with AI itself, ironically
helping you do it. This could honestly
take you one afternoon to set up once
you have all the required equipment,
which you probably do. I know you have
an old laptop sitting around. So,
please, please, please, if you take away
anything from this video, I just implore
you to start taking ownership of your
own AI life. It will not only give you
unlimited uncapped access to powerful
models, but it will also keep your most
sensitive conversations, your business
ideas, your personal writing, all of it
completely safe and private. But, I know
what tracks in this day and age, and it
is cheddar. So, start today, and I
promise you a year from now your bank
account will thank you when you've got
an extra $1,400
back in your pocket that you used to
hand to tech companies every single
year.